meyer habib à l'essai tobey je suis un
pécheur
[Musique]
voir il ya une carte de tu complètement
ouf dans l'ancienne casse d'escalier la
carte de l'inceste se veut dire quoi
cette merde pour expliquer qu'ils
étaient sortis avec qui dans l'année et
ce qu'ils avaient fait branlette promole
je crois que je peux comprendre je
simule quand on me lèche le nom figure
sur la carte qui a été dessiné dans la
cage d'escalier un cours d'éducation
sexuelle tutoriel là s'excuse strasbourg
vous avez fait ça avec qui avec votre
complice habituel harper
notre amitié était presque parfaite et
d'un coup elle explose et il reste plus
rien écoute on ne peut plus de toi tu
fais roues pour le genre tu les dénonce
c'est pas une raison pour me jeter l'eau
et des couvertures
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde le dit triste abri grosse
bouffe à la carte d'affaires faudra copé
déteste pas yannick est là il faut juste
que tu te fasses un peu mais
c'est une blague je suis plus drôle que
ça est ce que tu te rends compte à quel
point tout ça n'a aucun sens tu
ressembles à une des meufs dépressive
dorée la hausse mike bliss est kaunas et
allons-y
[Musique]
jonathan
ou est ce que tu as fait passer tu
rentres immédiatement bonne nuit